pour ce nouveau numéro de cette jazz à
Lyon je reçois ce matin François-Xavier
Pénicaud le président du MoDem du Rhône
François-Xavier Pénicaud bonjour bonjour
Alexandre vous n'avez pas vraiment
apprécié que l'UDI se rapproche de l'UMP
pour les élections régionales de 2015 en
Rhône-Alpes ont murmure qu'une liste
d'union pourrait finalement voir le jour
et quelle est la place du MoDem dans
tout ça tout dépend ce que vous appelez
une liste d'union en tout cas nous on
travaille à ce que une liste de
rassemblements d'intérêts territoriales
comme j'aime à l'appeler ce constitue
nous proposons Patrick mignolas comme
candidat à la présidence du conseil
régional le maire de La Ravoire en
Savoie président du de sa voix métropole
et qui est aussi et c'est ça qui nous
intéresse aussi beaucoup dans son
prophyle qui est un chef d'entreprise
d'un groupe de 600 salariés qui fait de
la production en Rhône-Alpes et avec une
part d'export donc c'est quelqu'un qui a
une crédibilité de par son expérience
d'élus certes mais aussi une crédibilité
de par son profil civil son expérience
dans la vie civile vous noterez bien
d'ailleurs que parmi les candidats de
premier plan crédible qui aura à cette
échéance ce sera probablement le seul
qui a une expérience de ce qu'est
l'économie réelle on est pourtant dans
l'évolution des collectivités notamment
des régions à seulement sur un
changement de périmètre parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé du changement de
périmètre ou Auvergne Rhône-Alpes mais
on a aussi sur une affirmation des
compétences régionales notamment en
matière d'économie et donc bien entendu
en matière d'emploi et c'est vrai
qu'avoir quelqu'un qui a une expérience
de ce que c'est l'économie réelle que de
développer l'emploi et qui n'a pas
seulement une expérience d'élus ou dans
la autonomistration ou la fonction
publique est intéressant aussi et je
pense que ça va être une vraie
plus-value vous prenez le rassemblement
centriste pour cette élection est-ce que
ça veut dire que l'UDI n'a rien à faire
avec Laurent Wauquiez le centre et l'UMP
actuel sont incompatibles pour ce
scrutin on ne peut pas parler d'un parti
comme l'UMP comme si c'était un parti
monobloc nous on l'avait dit dès le
départ si Michel Barnier avait pu être
choisi c'était lancé dans la course on
avait eu un certain nombre d'échanges et
on voit bien la ligne politique
qu'incarne Michel Bernier qui est très
différente de celle qui incarne
quelqu'un comme le renvoie elle est
différente sur la scène nationale on va
parvenir sur les polémiques nationales
elle est aussi très différente pour la
région et là-dessus nous on avait émis
le souhait qu'il puisse y avoir un
projet une aventure commune construite
avec Michel Bernier l'UMP a décidé de
revenir sur ces sur une attitude assez
sectaire en faisant le choix d'une
candidature qui symbolise les
antagonistes et qui symbolise disons
l'exagération des clivages j'ai envie de
dire plutôt que de quelqu'un autour de
laquelle on aurait pu faire un projet
commun donc l'UMP a fait ses choix nous
nous faisons un choix de projet qui
n'est pas celui de Laurent Wauquiez qui
est celui d'une partie du MP et si
d'ailleurs des gens de l'UMP veulent
participer de ce rassemblement de
territorial je dis pourquoi pas et bien
entendu l'UDI à mon avis à toute sa
place dans cette dynamique à condition
qu'elle ne décide pas de se renier vous
avez vu toutes les affirmations toutes
les prises de position Jean-Christophe
Lagarde et des cadres régionaux depuis
des mois sur le sujet on voit bien que
ils ont des désaccords de projets avec
Laurent Wauquiez s'il vous décide
d'aller sur les listes de Laurent
Wauquiez ce sera un reniement de fond
pour des questions de vie politique qui
sont pas à la hauteur de l'intérêt de
nos territoires voilà moi je leur dis
affirmez-vous François Bayrou était à
Vaulx-en-Velin ce week-end pour la
convention inter régionale de du MoDem
qu'est-ce qu'il en pense votre président
de cette situation Rhône-Alpes vous
soutient ah François Bayrou a été créé
très clair ce dimanche il a pris
position pour la constitution d'une
équipe de rassemblement autour de
Patrick Mignola et on a clairement la
réaffirmé il a réaffirmé chez un certain
nombre de vos confrères d'ailleurs là
volonté que il y est cette dynamique là
qui ne soit pas convergente avec Laurent
Wauquiez mais encore une fois c'est pas
Laurent Wauquiez qui est en question on
va peut-être arrêter de parler des noms
des noms des noms c'est derrière le
projet pour la région Rhône-Alpes
Auvergne c'est la une région d'Europe
c'est une c'est la deuxième région de
France et elle a le potentiel pour
devenir la première je le dis je
l'affirme et j'en ai la volonté et c'est
ça qui est en question c'est quel est la
cassipacité d'ouverture de cette région
par exemple sur l'Europe et sur le monde
Rhône-Alpes Auvergne de par ses qualités
cette région multipolaire les métropoles
qui la composent sont dynamisme à le
potentiel pour être un fer de lance de
la reconstruction de notre économie
nationale et je le dis aussi de notre
économie européenne parce que l'économie
elle est en souffrance en France elle
est en souffrance dans toute l'Europe et
il faut qu'on ait cette capacité de
reconstruction Rhône-Alpes Auvergne doit
prendre sa responsabilité là-dedans
alors justement vous vous avez vécu 16
ans en Auvergne 16 ans en Rhône vous
connaissez bien ces deux territoires
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce que chaque
région peut apporter à l'autre ronalpes
est une région qui est déjà multipolaire
c'est à dire que on a un grand pôle
d'activité autour de Lyon de la
métropole lyonnaise un pôle d'activité
autour de la métropole grenobloise
autour des métropoles savoyardes avec un
certain nombre de tissus de ville
moyenne et on a trouvé cet équilibre en
Rhône-Alpes qui est déjà une région
composite à la base notamment sur le
plan des cultures il y a des identités
diverses et c'est ça qui est intéressant
l'Auvergne souffrait un petit peu d'un
centralisme régional autour de
Clermont-Ferrand qui nous permettait pas
bien souvent de de bien servir
l'ensemble des territoires de l'Auvergne
je pense que cette réunification va
permettre notamment à l'Auvergne de
s'inscrire dans ce schéma multipolaire
et de bien retisser le lien avec tous
les territoires ça aussi ça sera une
différence la question du centralisme
régional c'est un point de divergence
avec un certain nombre de candidats il
faut que cette région fusionnée s'appuie
sur ce modèle de région multipolaire
maillet où on va pouvoir construire de
la proximité au quotidien et non pas un
centralisme et une méga région hyper
technocratisée avec une hyper
administration derrière qui d'ailleurs
des responsabiliserait tous les élus là
on a un vrai point de rupture aussi
alors on a vu que le centre en général
plus ces 20 dernières années perdues
toutes les collectivités qu'il
gouvernait dans notre dans notre zone la
ville de Lyon le département du Rhône la
région Rhône-Alpes est-ce qu'il y a
encore eu une envie de centre vous la
sentez vraiment et citoyens n'ont pas
envie de centre ils n'ont pas envie de
gauche ils n'ont pas envie de droite au
dernière départementale je l'avais
pointé du doigt d'ailleurs après les
résultats sur le Rhône ce n'est pas les
candidats de l'UMP qui ont fait le plus
de score ce n'est pas les candidats du
FN ce n'est pas les candidats du PS ce
n'est pas les candidats du centre ce
sont les candidats qui ont fait des
campagnes d'intérêt local les candidats
sans étiquette sur le Rhône c'est 41,61%
des voix qui se sont portées sur des
candidats sans étiquette pourquoi parce
qu'il portait des projets pour leur
territoire si le centre c'est un espace
qui n'affirme aucun projet qui est
simplement le cul entre deux chaises
pardonnez-moi l'expression personne n'en
a envie bien sûr c'est normal la
politique elle est là pour servir nos
concitoyens donc si vous leur dites nous
on est là que pour nous servir et puis
finalement on sait pas trop où on va ça
ne peut pas les intéresser je pense que
le centre n'a pas forcément toujours su
se renouveler ces dernières années la
politique a changé elle ne se construit
plus dans les projets uniquement sur de
la notube de la notabilité et c'est
beaucoup le centre c'était construit de
cette manière dans les décennies passées
il n'a pas su se renouveler et c'est
l'enjeu des générations dont je fais
partie donc je fais partie un Patrick
Mignola que de porter une autre vision
du sang qui va être beaucoup plus
offensive beaucoup plus un proposition
qui va savoir rendre lisible ces
propositions d'intérêt territorial
encore une fois je suis pas en train de
faire une campagne pour le modem pour
ces régionales on s'en fiche du MoDem on
s'en fiche de l'UDI on s'en fiche de
tous les partis au fond la question
c'est qu'est-ce qu'ils vont changer dans
le quotidien des gens qu'est-ce que ça
change demain de choisir la liste que
portera Patrick Mignola et on s'en fiche
qui soit mode amoureux qu'est-ce que ça
changera de voter pour lui dans le
quotidien dans le développement de
l'emploi des ronalpins de auvergnat dans
les déplacements ça sera une grosse
question aussi sur ces régionales la
question des déplacements il y a des
inégalités entre nos territoires dans la
construction des déplacements moi je
suis ravi d'entendre que Jean-Jacques
Chiran au moment où il a dû demander son
soutien à Monsieur Souchon dans la
région Auvergne ce soit enfin intéressé
à la ligne alternative de TGV Lyon Paris
via Clermont c'est une nécessité que
personnellement on est nombreux au
centre à le faire à défendre ce projet
depuis des années pourquoi parce que
c'est l'un des tronçons qui fait partie
de la ligne qui est Lisbonne et se
demander si on fait un tronçon de rail
et on pourrait discuter du lion Turin
aussi sur la même chose se demander si
on fait ces tronçons c'est comme si
lorsque l'on avait fait la connexion
Paris - Marseille on s'était demandé si
on ferait la partie entre Montélimar et
Valence et puis François-Xavier Pénicaud
cela fait désormais quatre mois que vous
présidez le modem dans l'euro n'est dans
la métropole de Lyon quels sont vos
forces quels sont vos objectifs est-ce
que c'est retrouver la vigueur qui était
celle de votre partie il y a quelques
temps moi j'ai été élu par les adhérents
du Mouvement Démocrate sur un message
très simple c'est que nous devons partir
à la reconquête des terres sont tristes
de conquête mais en disant il faut que
l'on rétablisse un contrat de confiance
qui était rompu entre les citoyens et
une panne conquête au sens nous allons
posséder les terres on n'est pas on
n'est plus cette terre là on est dans la
reconquête des coeurs pour cela il faut
déjà mettre les équipes au travail et
c'est ce qu'on a fait pendant les quatre
mois j'ai fait un gros travail de
structuration avec mes équipes de notre
organisation de remaillage du territoire
nous n’hésitons nous n'étions plus du
tout présent sur un certain nombre de
territoires aujourd'hui nous sommes
présents sur l'ensemble des territoires
avec des sections qui sont en place avec
des responsables qui sont actifs avec du
lien sur le terrain avec bon voilà on va
entreprendre d'ailleurs une campagne
d'adhésion dans les prochains mois parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
un grand nombre de personnes qui avaient
l'envie d'avoir un engagement sur une
voie authentique sur une voie
volontariste pour créer une troisième
voie qui soit pas construite dans la
détestation et la destruction comme vous
pouvez le trouver aux extrêmes mais dans
la construction et une volonté positive
de faire progresser les choses ça c'est
la démocrate c'est ce qu'on a fait et je
vais vous dire je suis très content
parce que le Mouvement Démocrate ces
dernières années avec son nombre
d'adhérents dans le Rhône qui s'effrité
de façon constante en 4 mois on a déjà
augmenté de 10% le nombre de nos
adhérents et bien ça c'est pas grand
chose mais c'est encourageant on a déjà
un peu de temps réussi à convaincre de
notre volonté de la possibilité d'avoir
une parole authentique positive
utile sur ce territoire et on va
continuer dans ce sens là merci
François-Xavier Pénicaud notre entretien
est à retrouver en intégralité sur Lyon
mac.com